hello looking to honest trailer
commentaries the show or we walked yeah
that's the fake intro thing I got that
one out of my system
this is all staying in
welcome to honest trailer commentaries
the show where we talk about that other
show that you hopefully just watch
before this show you stick around
there's deleted scenes at the end we
address your complaints hello today
we're talking about parentheses 500 days
of summer the movie title with the
parentheses so it's always number one in
your list of alphabetically-ordered
movies ICU movie I see what you did
there and it worked we watched this film
we had some thoughts and some feelings
mostly of the negative variety it's icy
it's touched a nerve with some people
both saying that we missed the point and
there is a discussion to be had there
and also that you know we're all just
morons so every week we are okay alright
so I get the I get the idea that like
know the movie is about how he was dumb
and he didn't know you know and and he
didn't recognize things and blah blah
blah the problem is is when you set the
movie up to curse out the actual writers
actual ex-girlfriend using her actual
name and calling her an actual [ __ ] and
that's the way we start the movie and
that's gonna color how I see the movie
for the rest of it
fair play yeah I do think I put this
movie this is the Fight Club of rom-coms
Tom is is is Tyler Durden incarnation it
is a film that you yet Tyler cardigan
the charming miss of Joseph
gordon-levitt much like the suaveness of
Brad Pitt just fools you almost it makes
you think like you're just automatically
on his dough I'd side just from looking
at him and just from being in 2009 and
you look down and you're wearing a
cardigan - so you're like well he's the
hero
that number one platinum selling banned
for decades yeah that obscure English
group The Smiths knew we were friends
for a reason wow you're so different I
lost my train of thought but yeah I
think that I was one of the alternate
this is one of the ultimate people not
missed the point but the point is
obscured one because of the actor and
and the point of view of the movie but
the other because like there is an
omniscient narrator walking you through
this film mm-hmm that's not Tom that's
like you can't say that that's Tom's
inner voice or anything like it is the
voice of God is also yeah that's the
thing for me was I saw this when it came
out and then again when we did this and
I also listened to the other solo you're
right there's plenty people that have
watched this in the comments doing like
we missed the point of the movie and and
I would agree I would agree with that if
the movie itself were not like a number
one not at all interested in summer
beyond her functions with Tom like it's
not about it looks like no it's about
how summer helped Tom grow it's like
well okay but how but but summer is is
ancillary to the story other than her
function to Tom that's it if they were
interested in her as a character and
like what about her other than she
wanted to be friends which she says
constantly with the idea that Tom grows
at the end I don't think your other
thing because if Tom had like realized
that like oh you're right like this I
need to I need to separate myself from
this idea that like that that this one
person could be my destiny and like
instead really focus on like being
present and finding someone who like you
know who I'm more receptive to and
instead of just fixating on this one
person who I've decided as my destiny
that would be the growth in his
character and how does the movie end hi
I'm autumn but no this is a girl that
I'm fated to be with it's like no good
mix back to one
but with women it literally starts over
so that's my big things like it
undercuts that entire message for me of
like Tom grew as a person which is like
no he didn't because he ends this movie
in the exact same place it was a
different quirky job that he's competing
expiring potentially former grow a new
girlfriend a new girl against but it's
the same exact thing oh this is the new
one that I'm destined to be with like
that's that then you've learned
basically he looks to Cameron gives like
a wink like yeah like well there's one
because yes most of the I apologize I'm
getting to the feedback we're all
getting the feedback part before we do
the feedback part of the show yes but
everyone's like no the point of the
movie is that that he's a bad person you
guys clearly missed the point
but that's so stupid to me because
there's there's one scene there's like
one specific scene where you're like oh
this is where we get there and that's
where his his little sister is like look
back at the relationship it might not be
what you remembered and that's the
moment where you're like oh this is
where Tom learns yeah this is where Tom
recognizes that he's been nuts he has no
idea what this woman is and he grows up
but he doesn't the montage is oh she was
a lot worse she was even worse take your
hand she's crying in the rain and so
like the the idea that a movie like
you're just throwing out an idea but
then not exploring the idea makes this a
bad movie it's like a stand-up like
giving a joke premise but then not
delivering a joke it's like just being
like you guys had this airline food and
then not giving a punchline or not or
like comics who are like oh the
president right and then they just wait
for you to and laugh and it's like no
give me jokes give me what you thought
of it like give me the arc of your idea
yeah well I do think I do think that
there was a there was an intent there
was an artistic intent and a point of
view to this movie which is like we are
just telling this very consciously from
Tom's perspective but they just didn't
follow through to me on the consequences
of that yeah like you'd like you said
he'd never you need one
of wait he's got this all wrong and I
don't think he ever really otherwise if
he's the protagonist and the voice of
God is on his side and the end gets to
end with this like then the movie is
saying like this dude's great like this
is your this is the hero the other thing
before we go sorry is that I do want to
hit back on his people that a lot of
people that I've seen like I would say
like well it's summers fault because she
told him that she wanted to be friends
but then she made out with him she
didn't say friends first of all she said
she didn't want a boyfriend
number one it's use very and and that's
also ascribing to this idea that for
every single person in the world
relationships are binary yeah you are
either you know only friends or only
going out exclusively with one person
it's like that's not true for everybody
there are people who as summer was
trying to express for whatever reason
they're in a certain place in their life
or they just are not ready to have a
long-term commitment I you know will say
like hey you know we may be we may be
going out maybe we even have sex but I
just I'm telling you and she was the
only adult in this whole thing and they
and she's barely but she says I'm just
telling you I don't want to be serious
I'm telling you right up front I don't
want to be in a serious relationship
with you you know like we can be
together but I'm not your girlfriend
like we you know we listening it's not
yeah it's and and the character Todd is
not listening but also people that say
that to me the audience is also not
listening because it's like if you look
at summers day like well why would she
say one thing when she meant another
like no she meant what she meant you
just cannot look at things in that
binary way when you kiss someone you're
not married to them because like when I
was like 15 to 19 with like a strong
Christian upbringing and an
understanding that when I turned 21 I
was going to get married and be in love
forever like if I kissed a girl and then
we weren't just in love I was like I
don't understand but
but that was when I was like 15 16 years
old he's 30 this movie would have been
great man if it took place like college
yes summer camp
all right let's watch this thing there's
no I guess the question is Oh people who
killed Augustus waters and Spider Man
yep
see if they can hear it 500 days of
summer strap in for a rom-com that's
right on both Rohm and calm because it's
more of a coming-of-age drama
except the guy who's coming of age is
like well pause I read this screenplay
they are only labeled as 20s but actors
age I believe 28 yeah he was like 28 I
think she was like 30 yeah there was a
marker in the script I forget what it
was I don't know why I'm wearing these
like he came here there was a marker in
the script and I don't know what it was
okay faith at that I think marked him
like around 28 or 29 years old but it's
like you're he's young professional I
mean if he studied if you went to
architecture school which I assume is a
graduate degree or D do that you could
study that depends on what kind of
market - if it's real architecture or if
it's the I draw other people's buildings
the skyline skyline I think he just
applied to that Art College remember
when you draw eyes
yeah my my understanding is architects
do it one building at a time yeah now
it's not a little too loud sir
but yeah his architecture mostly was the
was the rough sketch and then never the
will this hold up to any kind of you
can't just move buildings this is how I
would do it well that's great but those
buildings are there you can't city has
been built you can't put them up on
stilts and then like move them around
you went to the school of movie
architecture the George Costanza School
of Architecture but all right let's keep
watching okay 500 days of summer strap
is that rom-com that's right on both
Rohm and calm because it's more of a
coming-of-age drama
except the guy who's coming of age is
like 30 that has you time-traveling
through a relationship like a twee
Christopher Nolan because if you took
out the gimmick and watch these scenes
in order you'd see it's about a
codependent stalker and the empty vessel
he latches on to it's not like rock
paper sis on beats no relationship we
enter discussion about this because this
was also a quirky go to because Joaquin
Phoenix and her was also a greeting card
right and there's a Christmas movie
called season's greetings about someone
who brings cards but doesn't believe in
the spirit of Christmas is it just
because it's like the irony of somebody
who's like unlucky in love but in charge
of writing these things that express
emotion yeah
yeah yeah I think it's like it's
supposed to be the biggest contrast to
like architecture possible of leg right
I'm a man who builds entire cities with
my mind and I'm stuck unappreciated
writing this drivel for losers
tournament gamer sorry got the hole and
ninja sport night I'm a sad writing
happy things even the most generous
interpretation of his age 24 or whatever
I think we all come to realize greeting
cards are stupid at like 17 nobody is
like oh man this is so dumb like you
know the deal when you start writing
greeting cards that it's cheesy but he's
supposed to have like fallen out of love
with the media 2000 a night for him to
treat a job that allowed him to have an
apartment that night that casually
really and that is a very well staffed
and well furnished greeting you respect
the halls of American Greetings son
because they are giving you a Verne us
place to live he's have a good Union
there like they've like oh you're great
st. Patrick's Day
division and you've been fired at least
three times what he's making out with
his grandma the whole time he's making
out with her in the copy room like you
are at work yeah you are both at work
well that's my favorite thing is
thinking about thick is the he's at the
end of the movies walking into a job
interview and like it's I wish we still
did action credits because we can do the
city's like so that your last jobs like
well I quit without notice after a sharp
decline in my workplace production
following a failed workplace romant with
my boss's secretary okay well
autumns - laughter just Center it on you
oh the girl who I just tried to hook up
there's a number I just tried again you
haven't seen my sketches
what's your experience well I studied it
and then I've been reading this book for
three weeks
I'm very qualified can I see your
portfolio hand me your arm yeah that job
no no he and I are gonna have a rocky
relationship start anyways keep going
weird autumn go to school like she's
probably got a degree in it Tom doesn't
care he's always dreamed in it her name
comes after summer too awful friends are
you a lesbian did you mean no yeah we
didn't need both of them again waiting
for the scene where these two get there
come up they've never had come up in
says like actually they're pretty good
guys he's like I've got my wife for a
girlfriend that I've been dating since
high school yeah a huge knockers but I
love it just the hangover Bradley Cooper
is awful but hold like right out the
gate he's like taking kids field trip
money and he's like Vegas baby oh but
then at the end he loves his baby boy he
loves it he gives him a big hug at the
wedding he's a very good boy like come
on like they're bad we gotta raise the
bar because especially like a rom-com is
supposed to have like the buddy who at
least has some decent advice
I think they replace my crazy and sister
yeah it's like sister hey man I've been
listening to you for 15 years and you
never still know yeah yeah I mean this
2009 was a weird time I think this is
the only year this movie could have
existed I guess we're just coming off at
the like Maxim magazine mancho ideal but
like all the surface trappings had
changed but like the ethos hadn't
this is Maxim magazine in incarnation
this is right this is the Venn diagram
of maximum and the and the metrosexual
crazy yeah everyone was like let's give
men a special term if they iron a shirt
with a splash of like pre-chat Apatow
yeah but there are reverence yeah yeah
these very weird planets along it's very
bad truly once a generation 7
sweater-vests and 500 days to treat this
girl like a series of video game
achievements to unlock for sex he
wondered if anyone else had made it this
far
pause so I guess here's the issue with
the movie like that's a that's a big big
sticking point for me is that scene of
like she is opening up to him in that
moment she is telling him like her
deepest some sort of deeply personal I
had a dream once that's I'm getting to
because like on one reading like the
sympathetic reading to the movie is then
the voice cuts in and it's saying like
he was the he's basically only thinking
about himself in that moment the movie
couldn't even bother to write like a
fake personal anecdote for him to be
ignoring all she's just talking about a
dream she had just a dream she had was
like a fear of flying or something
there's like good stuff that they talked
about in the beginning about how her
parents divorce like did something to
her and how like even though she loved
her hair she could cut it off at any
second all of this stuff that they kind
of put in where I was like oh when are
we gonna get to that and we just never
got to that that would've been a great a
moment to be like hey here's how my
parents divorce affected yeah that was
manic that's right AC and get to the
girl part yeah you got all the pieces
yeah divorced man that would have been a
strong moment it really was confessing
something to him deep that he was not
listening to but nobody pays attention
when you're talking about the dream you
had you've never had a dream that was so
personal it was worth no it was
revealing I always just mowing the lawn
you're vice principal I knew my
boyfriend loved me when he asked me
about my dream once
we're dream and I left it there he's
like what was it about and I was like oh
yeah I mean it definitely says something
about I feel I feel comfortable taking
weird personal shots and making
assumptions about the screenwriters
relationship because he was so loud
about this movie being about this
relationship that he really wanted to
burn this girl to the ground over and I
think it says something that like
they're like well this would be a nice
part where the stand-in for your
ex-girlfriend like opened up and really
shared something and he's like oh man
did she I think she had a dream or
something once she eats food mints yeah
I don't remember she likes dismissed or
not I know I like this to be pretty sick
if I met a girl
the other thing being that scene where
they're renting the porno that they can
watch together so that she can want to
try to so tight the greeting card lady
to the the the store and then thinking
that therein is also much like the
greeting card company / architect is
like the too hipstery is dreams ever the
combination video rental store / vinyl
record wholesaler is mysterious yeah you
can you could possibly dream up for
their yeah that business is going out
the door the moment a tech company opens
up in town yeah I want a place to rent
DVDs and buy vinyl or rent vinyl and buy
a DVD let's keep going
geez a woman summer Finn was a woman
[Music]
but that's the toughest heartbreak when
summer suddenly reveals but their water
boyfriend and by suddenly I mean the
first time they hang out see you
boyfriend know why not and every time
afterwards they're about four more
scenes like this we cut for time I'm
gonna make here right there yes and
that's how people just like well she
shouldn't have led him on then it's like
geez literally they've already made out
I think they've already had sex
mmm and she's telling him again yes we
are taking these steps but I am
reiterating to you
given the current status of our
relationship even I am NOT looking for
something serious we're having fun
obviously and he's not paying it's the
same advice that I would give to any
like friend of mine who's dating like an
F boy who would do something like that
just leave like he's telling you exactly
what he wants
Tom can leave Donna doesn't tom is a
grown man at any point he can say um you
know what I really like you but I would
like something more serious but then you
know that's a different movie yeah but
that would require him to take
initiative which he won't even do it he
won't even ask her out like that's the
one thing he grows he he the one thing
he one Saturday of this movie is he goes
from not asking a woman out and
resenting the fact that she doesn't pay
attention to his Smith song as she tries
to leave work it is an open office plans
that is obnoxious foe deep cut Ferris
Bueller hipster [ __ ] sorry just like
cool deep cut songs like no it's the
most famous montage in Ferris Bueller
unless you think that's also a hipster
movie nobody's seen but also just like
would [ __ ] she won't even talk to me
he's probably a skank with 17 other
dudes of the week like that she's been
answering calls about greeting cards all
day he thinks she wants to talk to you
know go talk to her you freaking mutant
sorry I really don't like I'm sorry we
don't like we should go back and and and
scan through all of so edition ELLs
characters jobs because I receptionist
at a greeting-card company is pretty
quirky elf elf and a betta @al stored an
elf store and then she was like a in yes
man she's like a jogging photography
instructor like she leads people on
workouts where they also take Polaroids
as they're walking by for a while and
that's okay it's not Santa Claus
because they mutually respect one
another roses are red violets are blue
you because he thinks she's hot and she
collects words weren't you're fired you
are at work
used to call me anal girl so gather
round for a ten-year-old fill that much
like a ten year old relationship very
was when it was new but now it's
uncomfortable to revisit you cringe and
how service-level it was and you're
desperate to scrub your affection for
top rocker steam at charman's clear the
ending is titanically stupid 'madam and
I'm done with this in the play story I
know an architect made over the previous
girl the snozzberries taste like
snozzberries hit girl please just beat
this losers ass chill Colson no I don't
know we all we all kind of bumped on
that but I'm gonna jump ahead to a
viewer comment from Martin 58 who must
have long thick tails so yeah you guys
ever seen a puma yeah a Booma tail a big
okay yeah like that great colloquialism
the puma tails we all know and have
heard about I'm definitely looking up
poop yep let's see our Wi-Fi is really
bad this is a you still though Billy you
keep playing this might take Waddell we
got shoes yeah me too well actually it's
it yeah okay no oh no Tom you know what
that means
winter is pop us I'm just gonna pass
this around it's a tail it's a cat it's
a girthy tail yeah that's a thick tail
but oh wow yeah that's a lot of tail
yeah but it's not like a known thing Oh
thousand nine we're like Maxim magazine
was like who which cat tail is your dog
giving that maybe that's a maybe that's
a local thing like you know like a soda
pop yeah but I've this idea of the Puma
being this month thing and then it's got
a big poof of fur at the end that's why
I called the lion yeah I feel like that
there was a friend of the screenwriter
who was known as the Puma for like it's
like an inside joke wrote into the
script as if it were a common reference
that we should all do is it like a
pouncing motion is that it's a it's very
the world will never know let's let's
play it delete Z what cat is your
calculus like askmen.com the perfect
woman was a dude you could have sex with
oh yeah this was a true dude it was like
like Something About Mary yes like what
she likes sports and porn
pretty much all of them oh god that's 70
show Mila Kunis all of Mila Kunis's
characters you know it was it was a type
that was also known that 70 shodhana was
also one of the or Donna yeah Lauren
crap ones character was just like she
she was like cool because she was like
one of the guys you go outside you must
be a dude that's one we've had a hard
time getting over as a gender like I
feel like that's a like even when I you
know we were doing the the Phantom
uncovered for D&D like so many so many
people we talked to like any woman who
was like yes I played D&D everyone would
be like you mean like a dude
listen I love Maura has many common
interests with me I which I love about
her that's not like my I don't I don't
set her value as a person or someone
that I was going to come romantically
involved with based on how many of the
things that I like yeah she also liked
which is another thing about this movie
was largely based on oh she likes
everything that I like it's like well
maybe show some interest in what she
likes to do because like do they ever do
anything that has any interest of what
she wants to do it's always like I'm
gonna take you to look at these
buildings oh listen to this band that I
already like you know a lot of the
Graduate let's go that's the Graduate
yeah exactly so it's that's another
thing it's like maybe yeah maybe she's
into some stuff that you enjoy we do a
lot of stuff like if you're in your late
teens early 20s a relationship that's
mostly based on shared pop-culture
references yes sure yeah go for it yeah
just don't idealize this it's it's the
Fight Club was idealized this movies
yeah this is not ideal
anyway scenario you could have sex with
your dude the other term but not in the
gateway you sound gay no I know your
dad's feelings Sean Cusack remember when
he played cobra commander crazy stupid
live it you've got mail you should use
your full name douche bags pause a
comment that I forgot to pull but
someone mentioned that Jessica Levitt is
the king of movies that end with dumb
name reveals he's a full name Robin yeah
anyway yeah
fun fact yeah keep going ironic cuz he
has three holes already is that rain and
that's it she bangs she fans you guys
remember Super Troopers
that was funny let's watch Super
Troopers PFF yourself Christina
Hendricks husband nice and for Chad to
chose in celebrate good times 13 going
on creepy Rachel sister told Rachel
audiences Bob Vance administration Amos
the actual new girl I don't get next
[Music]
choice roses are red
violence is lawful summer should leave
Tom because he is awful a swipe right
seasonal yeah
finding keeps happening between her
giant bug eyes and his constant
squinting they had a shot at normal I'd
children's sure dead dude just had six
yeah John Bailey by the way I you know
we don't let him use the romantic comedy
boys now and he did great you did this
is this one in the notebook or to my
faves for that reason yeah I've been
laughing about this one all week yeah
yeah you killed this Super Troopers so a
lot of this we kind of addressed in our
talking the Pumas stuff so DJC 58 it has
some interesting interesting why aren't
you at your post
DJC 58 the movie you you need to rewatch
it different points in your life when I
was around 19 or 20 my sympathy went to
Tom and I just like summer but when you
watch it again six years later I
understand how summer feels and why she
did all that stuff it shows two sides of
a relationship and if you understand
both of these characters you probably
know how to really define love I think
especially like revisiting a movie
depending on your age because I
definitely now that I'm old enough will
watch high fidelity and now I recognize
the part where Rob Gordon's like what am
i doing and like finally really makes
the decision to like grow up and stop
making mixtapes for randos yeah but when
I was like 19 I was like what I took out
of that movie was Charlie sucks and I
love Rob making top fives being mad like
that's all it's a cat yeah yeah I get
that definitely so yeah a good movie to
watch
with some distance and some experience
under your belt Brian Tareq writes a
question for us commentary you point out
summer is merely a woman the movie does
that how much of her one dimensionality
do you attribute to Tom's projection of
her and I think that that's entirely
accurate it is Tom's point of view and
he's not really getting anything more
than the surface stuff but neither do
you got but you need that moment where
you find out that there's more yeah yeah
the movie is totally missing that any
and it can't be I have a fiance Patsy
and even in that conversation he's just
like what you just do whatever you want
don't you it's like don't do whatever my
creepy ex-boyfriend wants that's the
lesson that he was trying to should have
taken away from that it's like yes she's
allowed to exist as a human being
outside of what you've deemed to be your
fate together which is the whole point
of the movie that I think is undercut by
the last scene but but I would agree if
they had flushed her out more at the end
that inside the relationship summer
seems one-dimensional because it's an
idealized version of her but they they
don't do what Joe said which is go back
and add depth to it later beyond she
snubbed me and also even when she
becomes fully fleshed out she's just
like I met a guy but you don't yeah I
don't know who you never met a guy how
does that make you feel right like so
yeah I I think that's a good point but I
don't think the movie yeah follows
through I think they have they missed an
opportunity with the narrator to because
like you said like the narrator we don't
think is like an older Tom it's just God
and so like God had an opportunity to be
like she's a woman but also here the
following things that Tom missing the
point on like or not even like noticing
and like no one yeah well there you go
that's our show for the day but we have
an amazing editor named Kevin Williams
he went above and beyond before we'd
even finished the script of putting
together a little montage of some of
Tom's best moans I guess I suppose I
should give a clue for next week because
we're gonna go out on this next week you
are not gonna believe it what we do for
next week's honest trailer it is gonna
be crazy
mm so just that's our clue
and you know you'll figure it out later
so we're gonna leave you with a little
montage of Tom being an insane person
and and we'll see you next week thanks
for watching
going to the supply room do you guys
need anything I think you know what I
need
[Music]
go away
I wanna speak today
[Music]
your best friend who tolerated you
whining about this girl for weeks on it
you were essentially stocking up
[Music]
I just don't want to well you're not the
only one to get to say in this I do too
and I said we're coming
[Music]